así que tenemos la gráfica de igual a fx
por aquí y lo que queremos hacer es
averiguar cuánto vale el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a -4 así que qué
significa eso bueno un límite es decir a
que se aproxima mi función si la entrada
de esa función se aproxima en este caso
a a menos 4 si la entrada se aproxima a
un cierto valor y como vemos en este
ejemplo la función no debe estar
definida forzosamente en ese valor
podemos ver por aquí que f de menos
cuatro cuando x es igual a menos 4
podemos ver que f de menos 4 es
indefinido lo podemos escribir no está
definido pero como veremos a pesar de
que la función a no está definida ahí el
límite puede estar definido y de hecho
podemos ir en otra dirección algunas
veces la función está definida ahí y el
límite por su parte no está definido y
eso lo veremos en algunos próximos
vídeos entonces qué pasa aquí cuando
extiende a cuatro pensemos qué es lo que
pasa para valores mayores que menos
cuatro y para valores menores que menos
cuatro bueno primero pensemos en valores
mayores a menos cuatro cuando x es igual
a menos uno efe - uno está por aquí y
este de aquí es efe - dos este de 15 p
3 este de 15 efe de menos 3.5 éste es de
3.9 éste sf de menos 3 puntos 99 9999 y
si observas el valor de mi función
cuando x se acerca más y más y más a
menos 4 por la derecha con valores
mayores a menos 4 parece que se aproxima
a 6 así que veamos si esto es cierto
también en la otra dirección vamos a ver
si esto pasa para valores menores que
menos 4 así que este es efe - 7 éste es
efe - 6 éste es efe - 5 que es
aproximadamente 7 este es efe de menos
4.5
efe - 4.1 este es efe de 4.01 este es
efe de 4.000 601 y estamos arriba arriba
de 6 y parece que esto se está
aproximando a 6 de nuevo nos vamos
acercando y acercando y acercando al 6
mientras más y más y más cerca estamos
de x igual a menos 4 cuanto más cerca
estamos de menos 4 la función se estará
aproximando a 6